Looking backwards, I think that the curb appeal
of the great quadrangle lent a prestige to
the institution that made it great before
it was great.
It was a really smart move and the architecture
was well worked-out, and the great lawn was
a marvelous idea.
We used to drive in to the symphony and we
would drive down [Memorial] Drive, coming
from Fitchburg on route 2, then down the drive.
And we would have a lunch at a Howard Johnson's
that was up where the hotel is now, and we
went past MIT on our way to Longfellow Bridge.
And I knew the school and I liked science
in high school and I guess, that way, I just
didn't think of any other school that was
my choice.
MIT was very remote for people that lived
in Cambridge, even though we lived almost
on top of it.
We had nothing in common with them.
I don't even think, when we were living in
Newtowne Court that they had dormitories at
that point.
Talking about MIT, honestly, I never knew
that they moved to Cambridge.
I always thought they was here and started
here.
Of course, they've been here longer than I
have, so that's why I thought it was always
originally here.
The uniqueness of it being on the river makes
it almost something you can't miss, because
the Charles River and the Boston skyline is
unbelievable.
But even in the beginning, MIT was just so
popularly known that you always marveled at
it.
You'd drive by Mass.
Ave. and you'd see the big columns and the
stairs, and you go "wow," and you'd think
Massachusetts Institute of Technology.
Technology -- it was something great.When
I grew up we'd just got TV.
You had to wait for the TV to heat up.
So technology was what you saw happening,
and you knew technology was MIT and that they
were part of it.